er hatte die potenziellen opfer
angesprochen ganz freundlich zunächst es
war immer eine beliebte zeit also nie
irgendwie frühen morgenstunden späten
abendstunden sondern ganz normale zeit
in denen sage ich mal
die menschen unterwegs sind im grunewald
und umliegende waldgebiet
nachdem er sie angesprochen hatte hat er
sie dann mit gewalt gepackt und gewürgt
so dass er erst mal wirklich seine macht
demonstriert hat sag ich jetzt mal und
hat sie von dem hauptweg oder von dem
weg ab gezerrt in ein etwas entlegenere
gebiete um dann die tathandlungen zu
vollziehen dabei hat er wirklich gewalt
angewandt so dass die opfer sage ich mal
auch nicht um hilfe gerufen haben obwohl
vielleicht fußgänger unterwegs waren
weil sie wirklich wahnsinnig
eingeschüchtert sein er hat massive
körperliche gewalt angewandt und hat
damit die opfer zum ist ja mal in dem
moment zum schweigen gebracht
man muss dazu sagen dass er dann nach
der vergewaltigung wiederum eine andere
seite zeigte und sich um die opfer ich
nenne jetzt mal das klingt vielleicht
ein bisschen merkwürdig kümmerte er
versuchte dann sich zu verabreden
für den nächsten tag und solche sachen
die opfer sind zum schein teilweise
darauf eingegangen um nur einfach aus
der situation herauszukommen
was ihnen dann ja auch gott sei dank
gelungen ist man hat das ja auch gesehen
an der kleinmachnow tag mit dem fahrrad
also der täter hatte ja dann sein
fahrrad dem opfer gegeben
damit es nach hause fahren kann und wir
nun zugeschaltet bild reporter matthias
becker matthias was wissen wir bisher
über den mutmaßlichen täter der sie noch
kahlen kam 2009 10 mit seiner freundin
nach berlin nach deutschland er wollte
hierzu keine geschäfte machen gebrauchte
autos an kaufen verkaufen bisschen geld
machen
dann aber ist seine freundin zurück nach
syrien gegangen und er wurde hier in
berlin zwei mal polizeilich aktenkundig
einmal stand er vor dem amt
gericht hier in berlin wegen eines
einfachen diebstahls vorteil zu einer
geldstrafe
dann im märz 2020 wurde er bei einem
einbruch erwischt und da wurde er denn
auch polizeilich erkennungsdienstlich
behandelt fotos und fingerabdrücke
genommen
die jetzt zur identifizierung auch dass
vergewaltiger führten
es wurde er wochenlang nach ihnen
gesucht wie genau kam es gestern zur
festnahme wie sich diese ab die
festnahme war so eine mischung aus dem
taktischen verhalten man wusste dass er
in kurzer zeit immer wieder zuschlägt
nur eine festnahme konnte die serie
stoppen also beim viel polizei in
bereitschaft und als dann der anruf kam
wieder eine erneute vergewaltigung zog
man alle kräfte zusammen man hat
drohneneinsatz gehabt man hat spürhunde
gehabt man hat hubschrauber eingesetzt
medaille bild kann man reißt alles was
brandenburg auch nur aufzubieten hatte
einen technik wurde eingesetzt
das führte dann zu einem hinweis eines
anwohners in zehlendorf eine beliebte
gegend eine willen ging
anwohner haben den tatverdächtigen
wieder erkannt und haben die polizei
informiert ein hochrangiger
polizeiführer sagte mir heute noch
es gab die losung beweis ich eine
festnahme was auch immer es ging ja
gesehen wird soll ja unbedingt
festgenommen werden und wie geht es
jetzt weiter spricht der mutmassliche
täter vielleicht sogar schon die mir
unter vorgehaltener hand versichert
wurde ist wohl bei der festnahme mit dem
widerstand wohl mit leichten
verletzungen
das beschuldigten einher gegangen er
muss erstmal ins krankenhaus
er zeigt sich derzeit absolut
unkooperativ er redet nicht eher macht
gar nichts er sagt auch nichts und wird
hatten jetzt in diesen minuten einem
haftrichter zwecks erlass eines
haftbefehls vorgeführt
vielen dank matthias für diese
information dankeschön